all right where you headed youngster
yeah I'm headed to the Cobo building on
Jefferson all right yeah Cobo Hall
Jefferson Avenue so what you in Detroit
for I gotta do a presentation all right
okay yeah presentation okay what are you
present actually it's about how market
research can be interpreted with
out-of-the-box solutions oh so you won't
get this all outside the box all right
most people think that all customers are
a single demographic okay online trends
are less linear oh okay online trans
Linnea hmm also thinking about doing the
presentation naked no clothes on oh yeah
yeah make a presentation no clothes on
that's good afterward I might just piss
on the floor in front of everyone oh
yeah okay all right pissing right there
and funny everybody good then I might
just shoot everybody in the place you
know with the gun I'm hiding in my ass
yeah yeah gun way up in that ass that's
the way to do it cut my victims faces
off wear them as masks yeah mask on the
face ah
yeah okay ich bin ein Schein Heil Hitler
yep okay
all right here we are oh by the way when
you kill those people at your ass gun
make sure to use a serrated blade to cut
the faces out I'll feed the same
you
you